the breakout of three inmates from the
famous prison in 1962 has been the
subject of wild speculation for more
than half a century now a handwritten
letter is again raising questions about
whether the men survived the frigid
waters and deadly currents of San
Francisco Bay John Blackstone is on the
water just off Alcatraz Island with an
with new details about the mystery John
good morning good morning well when this
was a prison we might have been shot if
we got this close to Alcatraz on a boat
here on San Francisco Bay it was thought
the cold water the currents and strong
tides made escape from the prison
impossible but for 55 years a mystery
has lingered did three inmates actually
escape and survive ever since brothers
John and Clarence Anglin along with
inmate Frank Morris disappeared from
Alcatraz in 1962 the official story has
been they didn't make it the Federal
Bureau of Prisons say that they drowned
once they got off of Alcatraz and and
their bodies were swept out to the
Pacific Ocean but now a letter obtained
by CBS affiliate KPIX claims all three
lived well into old age my name is John
Anglin the letter begins I escaped from
Alcatraz in June 1962 yes we all made it
that night but barely Anglin cell is now
a favorite stop for tourists who can see
the vent he squeezed through when he and
the others made their break then floated
off the island in a homemade raft has
always been talked about through the
family
David Widener is a nephew of John and
Clarence Anglin my grandmother received
roses for several years after the
escapes no indication that it was really
from from your uncle's actually yes John
and Clarence the signature was on those
cards the letter was received by San
Francisco Police in 2013 but never
before made public I really haven't come
to a conclusion whether I believe that
that it's John reaching out or not the
US Marshal Service says the FBI could
not determine if it was real the three
remain on the Marshal Service
most-wanted list
along with photos of what they
might look like today I was awakened by
the siren at the time of the escape
Joleen Babiak was living on Alcatraz her
father was acting warden I can see why
the the FBI would consider it
inconclusive because there's no leads
here that you can go further with the
letter makes an offer if you announce on
TV that I will be promised to go to jail
for no more than a year and get medical
attention I will write back to let you
know exactly where I am
it adds I am 83 years old and in bad
shape I have cancer for him to you know
say that he had cancer and was dying I
feel like you know they should have at
least reached out to the family and let
them know that the letter existed if the
three did survive these treacherous
waters as the letters claimed they would
have outlived the prison Alcatraz closed
in 1963 the year after the escape but
the mystery remains open Nora
John thank you so much